hey guys do you know how to use cologne
effectively when how where and how much
if you use too much it's gonna put
people off if you use too little no
one's gonna smell it and then if you
spread on the wrong places it won't have
the effect that you hope it will
and smelling good as a man is super
important because it's automatically
going to make you more attractive tom
ford said good manners and good cologne
is what transforms the man into a
gentleman so in this video i'm going to
show you how to put on clone the right
way let's not waste any more time let's
get to the video
all right so to use cologne effectively
you need to know the don'ts of cologne
first
meaning
cologne mistakes
number one if you spray it on yourself
don't rub it in
why
well because it doesn't really work and
it changes the top note of the cologne
and then number two don't just spray the
cologne in the air and walk into it
why because it doesn't work
number three don't spray more than twice
on the same spot
why
because if you spray too much it's going
to be overpowering you know those people
who you can smell even before you get
closer to greet them that smell is so
overpowering
and you just want to get further away
from that
now the rest of the cologne mistakes i
will need to explain with some of the
other tips
so for now let's move on to the when you
should put on cologne
so what is the best time to put on
cologne right after the shower when
you've put on your clothes
that is when you're clean your pores are
open and it's the best time to do it
it's also great to do this at this time
because then it becomes a habit and you
will never forget to put on your cologne
now let's talk about where you should
spray it on your body
[Music]
so where should you put on your cologne
here here here here here here here here
where
well you can actually try a few
different spots including which is the
best your pulse points a pulse point is
a spot on your body where there is more
blood flow and heat which causes the
scent of the cologne to come out more
pulled points are those areas on the
side of your neck
on your wrists on the soft area on the
other side of your elbow and even your
temples
but of course
you're not gonna want to spray cologne
here on your temples now some people
spray it on two spots some three some
more than five and some more than seven
now i personally put my cologne only on
five spots this is what works for me i
spray behind each ear on my neck it
works great you'll get compliments
especially from your wife of your
girlfriend my wife loves it and it's
more intimate here as well
then i spray on my back neck now of
course this is not a pulse point but i
just like this area a lot of people just
focus on the front of their body all
right but then they forget about the
back if you spray cologne here on the
back of your neck it doesn't matter
where you go you will always have a
balanced scent all around you then
lastly i use cologne on both sides of my
collar or the upper chest area and some
people say ah daniel you shouldn't do
that he's gonna stain well i've been
doing it for a long time and i never had
any problems never any stains it
probably depends on the material or the
clothes that you wear but i never had a
problem and i do it for a few reasons
the first reason is it smells nice and
the scent will last a lot longer on your
clothes than it will on your body my
wife loves it especially when i'm away
for a long trip because she smells me at
home when she is near my clothes
and then third a lot of guys prefer to
spray their neck here above the collar
but this is a problem especially if you
shave because if you shave that cologne
can cause red spots and irritation on
your skin where you shave now you might
say hey it doesn't look like you shave
well of course i do i shave the top part
here of my neck so for me i prefer the
the collar here or the upper area of my
chest to spray the cologne but if your
fragrance wears off through the day you
can just reapply it here on your wrists
and then it's also very important to
know another cologne mistake don't hold
your cologne too close
here to your neck when you spray it it's
just like oh man you can just feel that
it's just like hairspray you can't hold
it here when you spray your hair you
have to hold it around here right it's
the same for cologne so when you spray
it you have to do it like this a little
bit further back more than 10
centimeters what is that around four
inches
now just a bonus tip you need to know
your cologne they're all different some
they smell a lot stronger than others
for example if you use synthetic cologne
they're usually a lot stronger than
natural cologne so if you have a natural
cologne you probably need to apply it
again later in the day when i get
cologne it's very important to me that i
get cologne that will last a long time
then how to perfume edp is around two to
three times stronger than i'll do to let
man i struggle to pronounce this every
single time i have to say this i'll do
tolet toilet i think about the toilet
every time i have to say this
anyway
when it comes to cologne the notes are
also very different so you will need to
know your cologne and you gotta try it
out test them out in this video i mainly
use dolci kombana the one for men but
i'll add my favorite list in the video
description down below if you want to
try out some great cologne and hey if
you're new here to my channel don't
forget to subscribe and also click that
notification bell so you won't miss any
of my next videos and you might like one
of these now remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys